e hoje vamos discutir a seguinte questão
qual as novas formas de organização da
educação nesse mundo em crise de saúde
pública e crise sanitária provocado pelo
pela pandemia do novo coronavírus e como
podemos projetar a educação no mundo
pós-viral
e é obviamente muito difícil fazer esse
tipo de projeção o futurologia do campo
da educação mas podemos analisar o que
tem sido feito e o que podemos esperar
do novo normal com base em alguns
parâmetros primeiro importante
considerar que a essa nova forma de
organização social que vivemos ela é
pode ser analisada do ponto de vista de
uma reconfiguração da articulação entre
o espaço eo tempo porque a com
isolamento o distanciamento social eo
isolamento domiciliar obviamente nossas
formas de organização no espaço e os
arranjos sociais provocados por essas
novas formas de organização do espaço
elas mordem
é consideravelmente a maneira pela qual
podemos aprender coisas tão o
relacionamento social base da
aprendizagem base dos processos de
aprendizagem igual aviamento sofre
modificações na dimensão do tempo nós
também sofremos um impacto interessante
porque o tempo parece dilatado então na
medida em que nós fazemos uma consul uma
construção espacial o tempo por sua vez
ele é dilatado daí a nossa sensação
psicológica e muitos de nós e que
estamos trabalhando mais fazendo mais
coisas fazendo inclusive alguns aspectos
de angústia é no contexto dessa dessa
nova dessa reconfiguração do espaço
tempo o que da educação tradicional do
arranjo social que tinham na escola e na
academia o mesmo a formação co
o de antes da pandemia está sendo
transporte como está sendo transposto
para as plataformas digitais para o
mundo virtual durante a pandemia e com
nós podemos que é que podemos prever
alguma coisa da nova normalidade no
mundo do me chamasse pós pandêmico foi
bem tradicional mente a escola pode ser
analisada é a partir de quatro dimensões
na escola é a missão lá escola se vê
tradicionalmente como instituição que
entrega conteúdo e avaliado do ponto de
vista de uma certificação e o faz dentro
de um contexto de muito disciplinamento
disciplinamento e diríamos industrial
quase a com baixa socialização a hora do
recreio então nós temos aí conteúdo
a certificação com alto disciplinamento
e baixa socialização pois vem parques
dessas coisas e muitas vezes todas elas
estão sendo simplesmente a transpostos
para os mundos virtuais sem muita
reflexão então não é sequer muitas vezes
é a de educação a distância que exige um
designer instrucional mas é uma
transposição mesmo em translitera mento
que faz com que nós tenhamos esse
excesso de conteúdo sendo de livre da
sendo entregue nas plataformas digitais
acondicionamento que tá longe de
provocar autonomia e as bases
cooperativas necessárias à a transição
alta ao trânsito das pessoas nessas
plataformas digitais ela com
socialização
a baixa a vi um tipo e certificação que
as pessoas esperam será confirmada de
volta no mundo mundo físico no mundo
presencial após a pandemia eu gostaria
de sugerir um outra visão da articulação
dessas quatro camadas ou quatro
dimensões e oferecer um exemplo de como
isso pode ser realizado e com eles têm
sido realizado a já agora no mundo no
mundo presidencial mas com articulações
e híbridas para o mundo digital perdem
eu acredito que é conteúdo não deve ser
o foco dessa educação na nova modalidade
na nova normalidade mas experiência
emersão dos aprendizes em experiências
significativas em contextos relevantes
de
a identificação refinamento de problemas
complexos e desenho de soluções
significativas então a gente transita de
só de conteúdo para a experiências
significativas sabem juntei tá é o mundo
dos a ser a nós temos que transitar
também do mundo do bicycle lamento que a
escola ver com tão cara para um mundo da
cooperação através da autonomia tô mais
precisamos de plataformas que favoreçam
a formação de times dentro de
experiências significativas para
resolução problemas hora colocar
conteúdo em plataformas digitais para
que os alunos entre aspas absorvam que
retém um certo aprendizagem são metafios
absolutamente falidas do mundo da
educação e da aprendizagem já
e aqui duas mudanças fundamentais de
conteúdo para experiência de disciplina
para a autonomia e nós poderíamos
naturalmente ainda é transitar do mundo
da socialização para construção de
relacionamentos entre professores e
estudantes tutores e aprendizes e assim
por diante então relacionamento baseado
na confiança não a socialização que de
qualquer forma a das construções de
distanciamento social para nós teríamos
muitos muitos problemas e resolver então
como é que a gente constrói
relacionamento pode ser uma nova visão
para a esse mundo após pós-viral e
finalmente as formas de certificação
tradicionais elas já são sequer
valorizadas a no mundo do
empreendedorismo no mundo das novas
configurações
e corporativas a nós sabemos que grandes
empresas como google por exemplo que
sequer exigem mais uma certificação
universitária para seus métodos de
contratação então de novo temos uma real
transição para um mundo pós-viral que
deve ser refletido agora a enquanto
estamos reorganizando as condições da
aprendizagem a que pode ofertar
plataformas digitais não para entrega de
conteúdo a sem autonomia com baixa
socialização e uma certificação para
depois então essas plataformas digitais
elas vão valorizar uma experiência
inesquecível de resolução de problemas
como é que a gente pode fazer isso
videogames por exemplo então aqui em
recife o porto digital nós desenvolvemos
uma plataforma de videogame base
em torneios emissões desafios e
resolução de problemas que estudantes se
organizam em pinguins para resolver
então esses torneios correm ao longo do
ano é com olimpíada de conhecimento mas
não é como é tradicionalmente se faz
onde os estudantes que não conhece uma
determinada dimensão do campo de
conhecimento eles são retirados da
olimpíadas esperem mas é uma olimpíada
de aprendizagem portão que eles eles os
torneios são recorrentes e as pessoas
estão sendo sempre engajados
curiosamente na resolução do problema
então eu não é o foco não é o conteúdo
não é saber os tópicos do ensino médio
do ensino fundamental por exemplo mas é
ser capaz de desenvolver competências
relacionadas a um determinado campo de
conhecimento através do experiência
merecida que constrói um novo tipo de
disciplinamento baseado na autonomia
e tem que colaborar e evoluir
estratégias sociais para resolução
desses mesmos problemas os professores
são convidados pelos próprios alunos na
forma de professores aliados então eles
cooperam com os alunos com vistas a ao
entendimento dos tópicos que estão ali
colocados finalmente nós construímos uma
nova forma de relacionamento baseado na
confiança e na formação de redes de
ecossistemas entre todos esses atores da
escola essa é a olimpíada de jogos
digitais e educação e experiência que eu
gostaria de compartilhar com vocês e
talvez oferecer uma nova forma de
articulação do espaço tempo no mundo
pós-viral nessa nova normalidade
obrigado a
e aí